have you ever killed someone and how did
that feel
the tough one
do you owe your life to anyone has
anyone saved you yeah I had um
uh earn my early years in Afghanistan
and we were dropping off on a single
load up a place called kajaki Dam which
is right at the top of the helmond
valley
and um
there's wires like the big sort of high
voltage wires you get here in the UK we
call those helicopter Killers because if
you fly and decide those you're more
than likely going to pull the whole
aircraft out of the sky so when we're
here in the UK we do lots of Rockies to
make sure that we look for them and we
see them before we'd fly an ignite
navigation routes
um and we kind of do the same in
Afghanistan but they're not marked on
any Maps you just have to keep an eye
out for them and um but this particular
set had been put up and we haven't seen
them so as we dropped an unsung load off
at the drop point
um we we sort of exited from the the
drop point and flew straight into a huge
set of 250 foot high voltage wires
um
and the whole aircraft also there was
allowed buying
um and
um the first thing I remember was seeing
the the wire spark out the three o'clock
of the aircraft I was stood at the front
door and the smell of burning
electricity just filled the whole
aircraft really badly
um I looked at my shoulder and the other
crewman had nearly gone through the
center hatch with the jolted there for
him and actually been saved by his
harness
um and the whole aircraft was wallowing
towards the ground which was like
undulating sand dunes and the pilot was
just shouting I can't see I can't see so
I thought we were going to crash I held
the front of my harness which is like
two webbing straps that fit into a
buckle and thought that we were
absolutely going to go crash land and I
was going to have to somehow get out of
the aircraft and about 15 feet off the
ground the co-pilot a guy called Marty
and said I have control I managed to
pull in power and climb this back into
the sky
um and what had happened the cop had
caved in over the handling pilot so we
couldn't say anything but um yeah that
champ that day absolutely saved my life
yeah without a doubt for me I wouldn't
be here today if someone didn't save my
life
um
in fact it was probably a few guys who
it was my entire Squadron who saved my
life really
um
we were on a special op
um near the northern border of Afghan
and we were After High Valley targets
once we'd broken through they had all
set up and yeah we just walked into a
wall of bullets
um
there's really nothing we could do about
it I was shot through the neck
second round hit me on the side of the
head but luckily I was you know wearing
my kevlar helmets so I'd Rico Shed off
uh the guy behind me was shot through
the knee and
um
yeah I was dragged out
uh
as the firefight ensued by the
the team coming in behind me and yeah
they started working on me straight away
in the middle of the night in the pitch
black
um
obviously they didn't know where I'd
been shot so the first thing they were
doing was trying to find the find the
wound fund entry wound
um stop to stem the bleeding uh pack the
wound and
and then keep me breathing so yeah I
really owe my life to about three or
four
guys on the ground my last tour
um
well on an OP I was sniper and give an
OverWatch in the green zone
and Yacht went well
civil targets got taken out
you know Happy Days in it you know
as you all know are for
five o'clock in Afghan pitch black you
know
beautiful ambient light you know from
sorry no ambient light but the stars are
beautiful you know and um
it came to about half four and we had to
finish this up so they went back the
patrol went back and we come off The
High Ground
got my vehicle and they have three
vehicles and my first core sign stopped
it's um
as a sergeant you're not meant to lead
you know your Junior course on leads and
then you go on someone there and he
stopped and I jumped out my wagon and
went around wearing jackals up on top
vehicles
and I said to him you know why aren't we
moving and he said
I've got a bad feeling about this
you know I'm not a religious man I
believe in fate and gut instinct you
know and he said um
I've got wife and kids at home Creek
I went hi mate all right I'll lead
so I've got my vehicle and um
I didn't want to go into the village
because there were too many VPS in the
village
so um vulnerable points so I what I did
I scooted round the village
and I hit a 30 kilo anti-tank mine
I got blown out
[Music]
um
the other vehicle the left side
my driver hit the steering wheel and
lost his legs
but I couldn't find him and I was trying
to crawl but as I was crawling my arms
were just collapsing on me and I could
hear people and that boo that constant
buzzing sound and everything's in slow
motion and I could hear people shouting
behind me stay still stay still stay
still
and I blood picked out my head
everything in the nose ears and I wanted
to find my driver I couldn't see him I
couldn't see him
um
and it turned out that I'd
um armored personnel mines around me so
if I'd have called any further I would
hit an AP mine
um
they found my driver where the Blasted
hit the right sorry the right side of
the vehicle or the sand went on him so
he was like camouflaging his gear plus
the sand and the only fan because of the
bloodstop out of him did he survive yeah
he did yeah yeah and um
I remember the lads just wrapping me up
you know their skills and drills took
over you know I wasn't
Craig Harrison then I wasn't Sergeant
Harrison I was a casualty you know and
they had to think as me as a casualty
not you know and they wrapped me up put
me in a
um
uh stretcher
and took me to the uh
emergency hls and then we got under Fire
and they started engaging us from the
village and from the green zone because
it was quite flat
and the Chinook came down as the Merc
came down it touched and went off again
because it wouldn't land because it was
pinging off
the side of the Mur
um
and they were
that we needed it because Cliff was
bleeding out my driver
and it landed again and
that's all I remember I saw I remember
and I remember waking up
um
in hospital
ambastian and I looked over and I saw
blood on this bed there's pure blood on
the bed and it was where my driver was
and I thought it where is he where
is he and first thing I thought you know
he's dead you know and they they said no
he's gone in for emergency surgery
trying to save him
have you ever killed someone and how did
that feel
that's a tough one yeah
me personally as a sniper yes I have
what did it feel like to begin with felt
I was in trouble
um
I was
in a situation where I had to because I
was saving other people from this one
person you know and it had to be done
had the permission to do it the green
lights you have to go through all this
stigma of green lights and God knows
what and because I've got a precision
rifle with a scope I can PID that Target
and I know what I'm looking at yeah and
you feel like you're in trouble and I
felt for about a week I thought I was
going to get a tap on the shoulder all
the time going can we have a quick word
of you you know why did you kill this
guy you know and then and then it I
didn't look at them as people after that
I just looked at them as targets because
if you start looking at them as people
you start thinking
there are people and you start you know
your mind starts you're overthinking
your what your actions and what you're
doing I think for me
it was a lot easier
um and then and this was my experience
being in the Special Forces was that
compared to being on on you know genetic
generic forces on the ground was
we had different rules of engagement and
in some respects it was a lot easier it
was easier being a sniper as well
because we had Ops to go once yeah take
Pacific targets Out and because you've
got that scope on that rifle you can
actually PID that you know I exactly
yeah I I do your maker and stuff like
that you can actually PID it and
ultimately that made it I think it it
was easier for your conscience yeah
[Music]
and I remember the the stretchers coming
over the ramp and um so I'm gonna get
emotional um they were all covered in
Flags so there was a rifles flag on one
of the bodies
um a new ninjag on one
um a Welsh for like on one of them and
each body had a different flag on it and
there's nothing you can say to this guys
it's gonna make that better